hello everybody and welcome to this
tutorial on a new opportunity to come
and work with the EU institutions
this time we are looking to select
specialists in fields which are very
high on the EU agenda even the global
agenda
and these are the fields of energy
climate and environments
as usual we have published on our
website this infographic which gives you
an overview a quick overview of the
different
steps or stages in this competition and
today we will look a bit into detail
and explain these different steps one
after the other
as said we have three Fields energy
climate and environment and you see the
number of successful candidates
indicated here so in total we're looking
to select 155 successful candidates
and candidates can only apply for one
field so they have to choose one of
these three available opportunities
the eligibility criteria for an ad6
competition because these are ad6 Level
competitions
are you that you need either a relevant
master degree meaning four years of
university studies plus three years of
relevant experience
or a bachelor degree which means three
years of university studies plus four
years of professional experience
now if I say relevant experience and
relevant degree this relevance is
detailedly explained in the notice of
competition the legal document
explaining the whole procedure and
getting everything or giving all the
details very clearly now to give you
some examples of which
fields of study and which experience is
accepted I'll give you some ideas here
so for the field of energy
degrees in different fields of Sciences
also in finance and law are accepted and
the experience should be in either for
instance energy transition energy supply
energy demand these fields
for the competition on climates again
degrees in Sciences also in economics
and Engineering are accepted and
experience should be for instance in
fields like mitigation of greenhouse gas
climate change mitigation low carbon
technology these fields and then for
environment again Sciences as a diploma
also law and economics are welcome to
apply and the experience could be in for
instance a sustainable economy in
biodiversity in ecosystem protection for
instance
then there's also a language Criterium
you always need two EU languages one of
which must be English and one of those
languages should be at least at level C1
and the other at least at level B2
the selection procedure follows the
normal path so to say so everything
starts with an application online
the first stage is what we call a talent
screener I will explain in a minute and
then the second stage is an assessment
center where candidates sit a number of
tests
successful candidates will then be
recruited mainly by the commission this
time in the director generals dealing
with energy climate and environments
so the first stage is of course or the
first step to take is the application
therefore you need an epsil account if
you already have one you use that one
you do not create a new account if you
do not have one yet you can easily
create one on our website
then you have to apply of course you'll
find the link to apply on the home page
of our website
and you can fill your application in any
of the 24 official EU languages
the talent screener part must be filled
in English
and the talent screener is a set of
questions to assess your qualifications
and experience I'll come back to that in
a minute and only that part must be
filled out in English
you have to validate your application
the latest on the 22nd of November noon
Brussels time so until then during the
whole application period you can go in
and out of your application and save
your entries but you have to validate by
the closing date
everybody who applies will then go
through this Talent screening stage so
you don't have to do anything more at
this stage you have filled out this part
basically this is a set of between six
and eight questions depending on the
field you have chosen
via which the selection board will
assess your qualifications and
experience in the field and the best
ranked will then go through to the next
stage which is an assessment center and
in this assessment center we will test a
set of skills and competencies
the first test to take is a test where
we assess your reasoning skills we test
your verbal numerical and abstract
reasoning skills
and you should take this test in the
other language than English so not
English but your other chosen language
you see the number of questions
mentioned here also the duration of the
tests
the marking overall you should
obtain at least 20 out of 40 combined
for these three reason skills tests
at the bottom of this slide you see a
link to our website where you can find
sample tests so I really advise you
to prepare this to train this
in this way you get to know the level of
difficulty of these questions
and also important you must be able that
you you should be able to solve these
questions under time pressure because
there is a Time factor involved in these
tests and by training this through our
website for instance you get you know to
know how this works and how good you are
and if need be you can prepare more and
rehearse this a bit
we have sample tests available in all
languages so you can really pick your
language and train this
the second test to take will assess a
set of General competencies we have
eight competencies to be tested and we
do this through two tests you will sit a
case study which is a written exercise
and through this case study we will test
four competence if you see them here
and then you will also sit an interview
which is a situational Competency Based
interview basically meaning that we put
you in a work related situation and we
want to see how you react
given the given the situation
through this interview we will test the
four other competencies
you will see this test in English Okay
you see the mark you mentioned and the
pass Mark again you need a combined pass
Mark of 40 out of 80.
after having tested the general
competencies of course we also test the
field related competencies your
knowledge in the field of the
competition and we do this through an
interview
marked on 100 points of course quite
important quite clearly and you need at
least 50 out of 100 to pass
the best ranked candidates will end up
on the list of successful candidates you
see again the number of people we're
looking for here and these are the
people that then will be recruited by
these different services in the
commission uh in the months to come
after publication of this list
this is what I wanted to share with you
if you want to have the full detail you
should of course read the notice of
competition which is this big legal
document giving you all the information
on the job description on what you need
to know and do on the different stages
of the competition uh gives you all the
information very detently so please do
read it if you do have more questions
for us you can reach out to us through
the website
we have a contact form available there
and you can reach out to us and we can
we will reply to each question you have
about this competition
you can also follow us on social media
to stay updated on upcoming
opportunities
for now I wish you all the luck with the
application and the testing in this
competition and maybe you will join us
someday in the future in the EU
institutions bye-bye